cruise ship passengers who unexpectedly
spent nearly two weeks helping hurricane
Irma victims are finally going home
Royal Caribbean sends some of its ships
to the Caribbean to help with the relief
effort one of them the majesty of the
Seas was in the middle of a five-day
cruise when it joined the humanitarian
mission DeMarco Morgan is at the port of
Miami's cruise ship terminal with how
passengers on board volunteered to stay
and help out DeMarco good morning to you
good morning Gail what started out as a
relaxing cruise quickly turned into a
rescue mission Royal Caribbean ended its
five-day cruise one day early and gave
passengers the option of tagging along
for its relief and rescue efforts of
course they are all well riding out the
storm at sea we spent you know 16 days
17 days together on sea together and we
all got to know each other in an
environment and a really tough
environment Robert Mahoney and his wife
were part of a group of around 70
passengers who stayed on board the ship
after the crew announced it their plans
to head to the islands devastated by her
mo this would be an opportunity to help
people out down the road we were glad to
stay on board and help out any way we
could the ship picked up passengers in
Saint Martin and st. Thomas what's
usually a party boat turned into a
floating shelter housing hundreds of
people
some of the rescued sing for joy when
the ship arrived in Puerto Rico and
thank to the crew that came to their
rescue it was horrible
what tango we made it thank you James
good job reception that we're warm
I saw people get off they ship the next
day and they were there almost whole
again within 24 hours
Royal Caribbean chairman and CEO Richard
fain was touched by how many of the
passengers stayed on board they would
talk to them they would help them they
wanted to help us distribute supplies
and so we were actually a little
surprised but quite pleased
sometimes disaster brings out the best
and sometimes the worst here I think we
saw the best in so many people I would
do it again tomorrow anything I could do
to help somebody you know talk to
somebody bring somebody back in the
lowest of all would be my absolute
pleasure now the CEO says the passengers
and crew were never in danger from urban
because the ship was able to hide behind
the mountains of Cuba and wait for the
storm to pass through so they could head
to those affected islands beyond great
story these people went from everyday
vacationers to humanitarians good for
them no regrets about it no regrets they
loved every minute of it DeMarco thank
you